do you feel like guys like the girls not
like them
you think that's a true statement no
yeah no no they don't know like you do i
would say they like to be violated small
small wait no actually violated guys
let it explain i don't explain that
but is this like
if you show that you don't want them
like that
then they're going to keep persevering
to but i know what what do you mean it
depends if i wanted you in the first
place yeah but if i know you want me
okay but i'm like um that might be age
specific i won't lie because if a woman
should if a woman's showing me nothing
i'm not going anywhere that might be a
beta man mentality
[Music]
oh
but the the alpha man
he
he knows what he wants so if you act
like you don't want him he's like okay
bet cool oh
i must say
he's an agent oh goodness i feel sorry
that i just said
if you like a girl and she acts super
interested is does that ever turn you
off no
okay yeah that's that's what i mean no
if you like a girl and she acts stupid
and she acts
you're going to be running by yourself
yeah but that's maturity like certain
guys they they have a bunch i'm going to
chase you
i don't chase
i i chase in the beginning if i see
something i like i'll chase it if i see
that you don't want me to chase you i'll
be gone
i think that's what most people though
oh yeah
i don't don't chase and be like
no
i just feel like once um once a girl has
been chased
and she actually starts to show the
interest
then he's like um
i can move on to the next is there
anything to that sarah or did he catch
you and maybe he depends on what he
wanted if he wanted to just have sex
with you then yeah yeah he got what he
wanted yeah but it's not there's imagine
there's no sex he's like he's chasing
her he's trying to talk to her he's
doing whatever he gets her she starts
she finally starts to talk and then
kabum he's like maybe he wanted to show
himself that he could still chase that's
but you can still get girls it shows
that women just basically get used
i mean that's not usually yeah he didn't
get set he didn't have sex she's used to
feed his ego i think yeah
then women do the same when they go on
dates with men that they absolutely know
they're not going to date again no i
wouldn't go on a man that i wouldn't
want to date but but girls do no girls
go and get three meals nowadays
that's a bit crazy it's not an anomaly
it's like 56 of women when surveyed
admitted to it yeah i feel like we have
this whole i say like disposable culture
like literally you could just toss
anyone about like oh i'll talk to you
today tomorrow no
so i think that whole everything is in
demand plays into fact like you can go
in an app and get 10 girls today
and then i can
in half an download
so that's the problem like back in the
days you actually have to
meet someone in an establishment or a
friend of a friend
mom dad someone someone's gonna
introduce you to someone whereas now
yeah but what are you looking for that's
the real question
are you looking for a hook up or are you
looking for a relationship are you
looking for marriage are you looking for
something serious do you get what i mean
so if you're in an arena with guys who
are looking for a hookup and you're
looking for marriage it's not going to
work is it and then if you're going for
girls who are looking for a hook up and
they're going to hit you up just to go
on a date to have a meal that's a bit
mad you can kind of tell when a woman
doesn't like you and she's just there
for the meal but then it's kind of like
a pat on your back um a lot of girls
know how to act on a date like
everything's cool you know what i'm
saying like
they can act like everything's cool when
they're nice and then
they won't see
but i think a lot of guys have that
understanding when they go out that
they're going to blow so much cash on a
girl i don't know okay maybe type of
woman why that type of woman i might not
even know you in this is what you think
is me right
i said you're talking to a man who was
in like a relationship for 10 years i am
very well versed in grand gestures i
know what a grand gesture is to my woman
i'll take you on a holiday i will
buy you things valentine's day birthday
i was very well versed in it i'm coming
from that and i'm coming into a
marketplace where women want grand
gestures and i've just met you are you
crazy my woman got grand gestures
i don't know you
let's go for a picnic in the park and
i'll have a talk with you do you know
what i mean i'll see you let's go for a
coffee and then and i'll see what's
going on don't ask me for grant don't
ask me to spend two three four hundred
pound in a restaurant at hackathon i
don't know you yeah but you see sorry
took up but like
i like the grand gestures however i
don't expect it from you if i say let's
go somewhere nice best believe i'm ready
to put in
what do you mean we haven't got time man
i've got time for what you want to pay
for me on a first date no no not pay for
you oh okay we all put in every like
let's go somewhere nice and enjoy the
food because i'm sorry like i don't want
to say i'm a bit boujee but i'm a bit
[ __ ] bougie and i don't i don't like
i can do picnic in the park give me m s
yes i'll do picnic in the past in the
park
i will provide the m s because that's
and she knows that's that's just what
i'm like i don't care like i don't i'm
not bothered about what you have what
you don't have like as long as
i'm happy in this like then i'm cool you
need to be by yourself
piss off like you do you need to be by
yourself i am not myself that's what i'm
saying but you need to be by yourself
like you're you're acting like the man
in this no i'm not acting like that man
i don't know i'm acting like the man i
just i'm not going to settle for
bs because someone doesn't want to give
it to me like give it to you what
obligations do they have to have you
don't have an obligation to give it to
me but if you want something from me
you're going gonna have to show me
that
i'm i'm actually worth you even getting
that okay well what are you showing to
him what am i sure yeah like what are
you what are you doing chasing you down
what does he get i'm a very intelligent
woman i'm very caring i can be very
submissive it's just that you you can be
submissive that's a huge choice it's
it's a choice i can't every woman has it
i'm not going to submit to every man
that i meet
no no no submission should be your
default setting your energy when it
comes to men yeah but you can you can't
because
all right if i said as a man i will
only be masculine for the right woman
so
exactly right exactly but that's how it
sounds to men when you say i can be
feminine or i can't be submissive
they're like oh i don't want to deal
with that headache i'll just find a girl
who who is submissive
but like that sometimes just because if
i ask a guy to do something for me why
is it taking you 10 years right done
like
today i've asked you the nicest way
possible cherry on top everything but
it's taking you 10 years now i have to
take it to my own initiative to do it on
my own yeah so when you keep doing that
when you have to keep doing certain
things by yourself you will have that
mindset of
i will choose to and i will choose when
to be submissive if but
like i don't know the guys that you're
around like i said i'm i'm a little bit
older like i don't know but
like i said all i'm saying
is the expectation of a lot of
women
wanting certain things when i know as a
man what i can provide and what i have
provided in the past
i'm just like you're not you're not you
don't deserve that well and i'll give
you an example my dad's a one percent
guy so in top income earners he had one
percent he had 10 kids with my mom and
if my mom demanded these ex
so he's one percent earners like he
he's a multimedia yeah yeah he owns a
software company he's
a lot of like women
would have overlooked him because my a
lot of wealthy successful men aren't
trying to spend money like that my dad
is cheap yeah he's not he's not going to
spend a bunch of money on a [ __ ]
like i'm sorry he doesn't know you
and so and so then you're gonna put
yourself as too high you're gonna put
yourself like in okay like and same with
my brothers all every single person in
my family makes six figures that is
older than me so all of my brothers
they're engineers they're successful
they are tall they are good looking they
are there are a lot of things that women
want and if and i'm telling you if they
heard oh i need to take you on a nice
date or we'll split it we have to go
here because you're making it about you
and so they're going to overlook you
because they're like well that just
sounds like a headache yeah like i'm
going to take the nice like the nice
girl that wants to get coffee because
she wants to get to know me exactly
because the date is about a date right
in my opinion it's about getting to know
one another we can get to know each
other we don't have to have a nice
restaurant to get to know each other i
want to get to know you want to get to
know me we can do that in a setting
that's nice it doesn't have to be
sparkly and with you know diamonds and
crystals and all that stuff
i wasn't talking about the hackathons
though notice i said we can go to a
picnic in the park but i just like mns
that's just me personally as a person so
at the end of the day like this is fine
even down to like when i have been
online and i've seen these
weird men that want to be doing up oh
i'll take you to this place i'll take
you to that place i find it unattractive
i find it scary i feel like you're
trying to lure me into something that's
not real and then you know what's the
scary part i have met
and i'm sorry to make this personal
but i have met somebody
online thank god i didn't meet them in
person who ended up being an actual
convicted sexual offender thank god i
didn't fall for the glitz and the glam
that he was trying to
throw at me because imagine if i did
what would have happened then
it would have got scary
and also too another thing that i've
noticed
especially like
from
mid-20s going to like yeah mid to late
20s it's a lot of guys are becoming lazy
and the reason why i say that is because
i don't know if it's because you can get
access to so many women or
um just get access to anything
the
willing to push to like actually put
effort to meeting someone or like
actually come up with an idea
be proactive
it's because okay i'll tell you there's
two reasons one it's the 20 80 rule so
80 of women are
20 of men have access to 80 of women
because if you ask 80 of women what they
want in a man they list 20 of men
so we're all going after the same guys
so it's just supply and demand those
guys can get a lot of girls a lot of
proactive men are now disappearing a lot
of white proactive
do you know what i'm a pro i would call
myself a proactive man but i'm
when i'm proactive
that's just my default position like
some people's default position is not
proactiveness
do you know what i mean like some people
are
dtf
do you know what i mean like
just down to [ __ ] like it's like oh
they're still they're not trying to go
on days they're not trying to do all of
that but that's what i said earlier you
know you have to discern who what type
of person are you
do you get what i mean you you're
looking at the the man but you have to
take accountability for yourself first
and then put forward your best self i
think that's what's happening now like a
lot of people are getting confused
that's right and then we've and also
with the men that you're attracting you
have you know if you are attracting the
same type of guy in
the same type of guy in different bodies
what is it that you're putting forth
that's allowing these
those men to be in your space
um
um having high demands of men that
clearly can't perform to that level it's
like a losing battle do you get what i
mean so
it's good to have expectation obviously
you have standards but are your
standards realistic
do you get what i mean as as a woman i
know i can't go to a place where there's
millionaires and be like yeah i'm
demanding this in this knowing that i
personally i'm not up to par
you know so it's accountability can you
can you imagine
wanting princess behavior or or
demanding princess behavior and you're
not my princess
like
it doesn't make no sense like you're
asking men that you have no idea about
you don't know the i'm not saying you
ladies but i'm saying ladies and
gentlemen they're asking men to treat
them like a quote-unquote princess
you are not my princess
what obligation do i have to treat you
like my princess i'll treat you like an
individual and a person with respect but
you're not getting all the glitz and
glamour yet that's that that's earned